it is early morning and Iraqi special
forces are rolling into action the edge
of Mosul is closed an armored column
curves across the fields the sound of
gunfire is everywhere but despite the
overwhelming firepower dangerous
constant this mortar round misses us by
20 meters as the smoke clears the
casualties appear the chaos reflects
what these men are up against American
Special Forces lend a hand
[Applause]
taking out the Islamic state mortar team
that had just found its range
moving forward we join the Mosel
division to the new frontline a perilous
bumpy journey across nowhere is safe
here Isis have spent the last two years
laying explosive traps for the advancing
army now entered this industrial area a
bit Swire
this is the last town before you get to
the city of Mosul
it's about two miles away but it's slow
progress each and every house they're
going through has to be searched to make
sure there is no Islamic state this is
now urban warfare and for many the
battle is personal as we interview the
commander another airstrike comes in was
stationed in Mosul in 2014 and had to
run for his life
when Isis took the city as an item we
were very sad for the people that we
lost now God willing we will take
revenge on Isis for the day they killed
our friends and for all those who fought
with us and every time we kill Isis we
feel that the blood of those who died
was not in vain admire up to Cudahy
in Islamic states with its passion for
death and destruction was once feared by
these men but with the gates of the city
so near they're now determined to avenge
their honor
Alex Rossi Sky News on the outskirts of
Mosul